everybody was going on play here and we
are in Chicago for a week of shows
Chicago theater was built in 1921 and
was the first big movie palace and with
the prototype for the rest of movie
palaces that opened throughout the
country
now of course movie palaces have been
replaced by this this is definitely the
way to watch avatar built in French
Baroque style the grand lobby of the
Chicago theaters modeled after the royal
chapel at Versailles everything about
this historical old building is gorgeous
and this is where we're staying that's
right
this place goes by a lot of names
sadness central a stink box turd alley
but to us we just call it home the
forward-thinking open floor plan is
great for morale it's great for
communication it's especially great
Coenen microwaves is fish every morning
at 11:30 salmon all right here we are in
the ad hoc Conan green room we've
decorated the green room with awesome
pieces of fan art there we go we see
Conan towering over Chicago here this
artwork here it's Conan now shooting
laser beams and and destroying things
and fighting UFOs really chosen pieces
that show Conan to be a powerful
all-encompassing figure to make our
celebrities feel incredibly small and
humble like you're an hour show mother
that's right
cave yourself one of the coolest things
about the Chicago theater is every show
that comes through here gets to make
their own little stamp on the wall to
kind of commemorate their performances
so Peter Allen and the Rockettes this is
awesome
Dreamgirls and over here we have is
either Ricky Gervais or Freddy Krueger I
think Broadway show that no one
remembers post-apocalyptic wasteland
with horrible radiation burns all over
his face I love this is how they
commemorate Ricky Gervais staying here
someone said after we're done painting
this yup that's Ricky Gervais
nailed it some of my favorite musical
acts have performed the Chicago Theatre
Lauren Hill look at this that's
beautiful
rush apparently did this
21:12 dudes I get this great idea let's
just do Picard and right Grinde it'd be
awesome
of course our show he's been here before
in 2006 when we were Late Night with
Conan O'Brien and we did graffiti of our
own here at sea we all sign it there's
my name right there his proof that I was
here and you can see Conan's signed it
right there he drew his little this
thing and sign at COP o6 someone tried
to scratch this off so I don't know what
you did to offend the people of the
Chicago theater but I'm sorry so that is
the tumor the Chicago theater hope you
enjoyed it if you're in the area come on
down to see a show here it's really
really a gorgeous place and I think it's
time to commemorate our week of shows
here so let's do it
all right coming in 2012 boom nailed it
see you guys next time
[Music]